supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson is back on capitol hill this
morning for a second day of senate
questioning senators quiz a federal
judge for 13 hours yesterday on a wide
range of topics republicans pointed to
her sentencing record in child
pornography cases and her work defending
detainees at guantanamo bay
do you support the idea did you support
then the idea
that indefinite detention of an enemy
combatant is unlawful
respectfully senator
when you are
an attorney
and you have clients who come to you
whether they pay
or not
you represent their positions before the
court do you believe the voice of the
children is heard when a hundred percent
of the time
you're sentencing child pro those in
possession of child pornography to far
below what the prosecutor's asking for
yes senator i do your chart does not
include
all of the factors that congress
has told judges to consider including
the probation office's recommendation
in these cases
joining us now from washington are chief
legal correspondent jan crawford and
chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa they've each
covered at least half a dozen supreme
court confirmation hearings good morning
to you both jan let me begin with you
this is the first time we've seen judge
jackson defend herself against
republican lawmakers during these
hearings um senator ted cruz his line of
query to judge jackson seemed to
indicate to the first black woman ever
to be nominated to the supreme court
that she's soft on crime she's soft on
pedophiles and that she holds views that
whites are somehow oppressors
what did you make of her reaction to
those questions well look i mean i think
throughout the day i mean she was this
mix of forceful when she needed to
defend herself and you know then
compassionate when she was talking about
her family and some of her hard
decisions that she's had to make as a
judge including in those child
pornography cases which she's handled as
a federal trial court judge you saw
senator cruz senator josh hawley really
kind of go after her on the allegation
that she was lenient in sentencing these
horrific child pornography offenders but
vlad i mean there is just no there there
i mean if you look at her sentencing in
those cases it's not out of whack with
how other federal judges approach these
cases it does not take into account
what we heard from those republican
senators yesterday does not take account
that her sentences were actually in line
with what probation officers were
recommending in those cases so i think
today they're going to move on and focus
more generally on how she is maybe a
lenient sensor in other cases but you
know there was no uh i mean they got no
traction from that and i thought what
was interesting is that you know you saw
her personality really uh come through
in that questioning you know she was
forceful but then she was compassionate
and talking about how hard those cases
were it's been very effective i mean
it's like when you're trying i thought
yesterday you know when you're trying to
strike a match uh and it won't light you
know there's just no spark you saw the
republicans trying to strike that match
but there weren't any sparks which i
mean from her perspective i think that
is a very good thing
yeah i mean uh robert i saw a headline
in the national review the national
review that said josh hawley's attacks
on senator on the judge are disingenuous
that is the republican consensus at
least among some senators behind the
scenes and when i pull them aside they
say that these hearings are not just
about judge jackson they they are a
prison for the upcoming midterm
elections so many of the issues that
republicans want to be talking about on
the campaign trail beyond ukraine beyond
the economy crime matters of race
matters of gender they are bringing up
in these hearings it's a reflection of
issues they believe will motivate their
own voters ahead of the november
elections
i'm so glad you that you made that point
robert because i was wondering if some
of that line of questioning was even
relevant to why she was in the room
yesterday but i know you've been
speaking with lawmakers on both sides of
the aisle about this do you get the
sense that there will be some
republicans it's so partisan these days
in washington do you get the sense that
any republicans will vote for her
here's who i'm paying attention to gail
two of the republican senators who voted
for her confirmation last year to the
federal bend senator susan collins of
maine senator lisa murkowski of alaska
and late last night gail i pulled aside
a few republican senators and asked who
else they say pay attention to retiring
republican senators who may not feel the
same obligations politically to vote
against judge jackson they could come
out in support of her in the coming days
jan what do you make of senator cory
booker's exchange with judge jackson
asking about her parents and her
children getting a bit emotional do you
believe that strategy for the democrats
is going to work
oh i mean nate i mean that was striking
you know sometimes in these hearings
there's going to be this moment where
you know you can just feel the fight
just leaves the room and we saw that in
the confirmation hearings for justice
alito for example his wife burst into
tears rushed out and i thought senator
booker's questioning came pretty close
to a moment i mean it was among the most
powerful of the day not only that
exchange you mentioned about her parents
but also when he asked about the high
murder rates of black men her worries
for her own family she called it
anguishing something i know she said all
too well that revealed that personal
side of her and then of course on the
other side of the aisle there was a
misstep by republican senator kennedy
from louisiana who described her as
articulate
as if that's somehow you know surprising
for a star debater harvard harvard law
grad who's been a federal judge for a
decade um so but i think that's going to
be interesting to see how all of this
you know what we saw with the powerful
questioning from senator booker and then
that misstep by senator kennedy how that
affects some of the tone of today's
questioning
well we then we know the numbers are in
her favor you know she certainly is
going to be confirmed do you think this
is still the best way to do this guys
knowing what the outcome we already know
what the outcome is going to be seems to
lend itself to a lot of grandstanding
that's always been the case i mean
robert knows that just as well as
anybody i mean it's always more about
hearing the senators talk but we do the
american people do get to see
judge jackson and it's like that that's
really valuable i think bob what do you
think
gail it is the united states senate i'm
never surprised to see a little
grandstanding in this chamber
[Laughter]
true that sort of sums it up
very accurately i said spot on thank you
bob thank you thank you jan and robert
thank you so much